afterdeath Communications I'm sure a lot
of people have experienced that where
you you've lost someone you love and
you're probably grieving when these
things happen and you you you you sense
you have some kind of experience where
you feel that you are getting a
communication from that person you don't
need a medium for that you can get a
direct communication it can come in many
forms and it's absolutely unprovable
it's totally
subjective but um there's a sense of
knowing when something like that happens
and it's very meaningful to the person
receiving it and I bet a lot of the
listeners right now have had those kinds
of experiences and most people don't
talk about them or they do just among
their family members or their close
friends but it's it's very I had a
number of these events happen to me when
I lost my brother and it's just very
very in some ways more compelling
evidence for an individual than any of
the research could ever be because it's
it's it's your own experience of
something